And yes guys
I'm super invested here in the new iact guidelines
Or travel guidelines
So much news I watched
Let's talk about it
Our Department of Justice said okay
Your basic travel documents is your passport
Valid six months from the date of departure
Your valid visa if ever needed
Boarding pass
At least your confirmed return or rounded ticket
Now the most controversial
Proof of financial capacity
Under Secretary said
You can find proof of financial capacity
If you're going to a country that is visa
Freezer
Your rc and countries
But if that country has a visa
Technically
You don't need anymore
Because of that
You already showed that when you applied for the visa
So a lot of them are also saying
Okay is've been seeing a lot of also people saying that
What is the original birth certificate?
Since the guideline is originally written
It is personally
Believe you have to bring the original
Because he didn't write a photo
The cap is allowed
He was originally day
The new one here at two point six if you can see here
The primary is o
Isn't your immigration officer now
Tell you what the reason is
Why weren't you boarded
or passed by
Again guys
This is me as a citizen of the philippines
Making this content
But based on whatever is found on youtube google
News channels out there as well
Personally my tip when I travel
At least we know how to understand him
Or how
They understand our guidelines
Of course
People understand differently
But you know that's how it is
It is also believed that sooner or later
There are also many lawyers here on tiktok
My gosh hi tiktok lawyers
Definitely don't give their inputs here
Also how should he be understood
Number one
I'm not part of iacat either
I'm not cid either
Neither am I the Department of Justice
And besides
Nor am I the department beer of immigration
So again I just understand how to
So guys it's just
It's a bit of a follow it to that day because
At the end of the day occasionally
We might be on the losing end so
And then my next trip
Definitely
I'll just prepare all of these documents
It is hard to know what is annoying to know
It's confusing to know
But again
The guidelines is there